Aloha rejects its Greg here with Kyle -
Kyle I remembers I called him in this
short film we shot Kyle fryer Minh oh I
gotta give you updates on that
oh yeah we're actually gonna make it in
two parts oh whatever we have to shoot
another scene oh cool yeah we're gonna
reshoot the last thing sleeps in on this
yeah as Lisa's out of town for a month
so probably will come out to like
January or February that's all right
but hey check that out check that out
when it's out yeah free fire free fryer
red band trailer it says brie Larson
action movie
this trailer came out like a month ago
there's a subscriber who's been my
phone's dead that's a lie just don't
want to look for it the subscriber asked
for this this video for weeks now he's
been asking her like they need to check
this out and then he I saw a comet today
or he's like please do it no one's done
it you gotta do it and I was like fine
so I'm telling you I'm kind of excited
because just looking at the red band
already
it's except strong violence pervasive
language like [ __ ] per sexual references
in drug use I love drugs
a lot of people out in California I
noticed do cocaine I've done cocaine
once in my life wasn't in California's
action New York where coke is very
popular if any when I collide her videos
does coke hit me up
schmooze no more like schmoes blow you
know what I mean
all right let's army
you're on a different
Oh God
cheaters bring a snapper so that's what
a [ __ ] brain looks like
oh sweet
Wow it's crazy
oh I okay I regrets having waited a
month to watch this trailer dude oh it's
[ __ ] crazy I love films and contained
environments yeah and this is such an
interesting kind of container barge
these guys a lot of guns
and they're all like you're trying to
shoot at each other and it seems like
people are like switching sides and
switching allies friends because bozos
become allies like it's like an action
movie in a play format yeah I was just
gonna say it's definitely like you could
do it on the stage but it would be not
probably quite yeah the dialogue is so
freakin hilarious yeah this feels like a
nasty mean movie with some actors having
a lot of fun though they all look like
they're having a great time I love
sharlto copley I think he excels in like
weird roles yeah this is clearly a
comedy right yeah it's like an action
comedy yeah and brie Larson you know
just won an Oscar and who would the
transition to go to and Killian Murphy I
love - I think killing represent great
accurate oh yeah I'm actually really
happy
armie hammer got something I mean I know
he comes on have you know much about his
family's families
they actually tried to buy Arm and
Hammer oh did they I'm not even Jewish
so they could change it - Armie Hammer
well his real name is Armand Hammer I
guess but he goes my army his stage name
okay he hasn't had a lot of good roles
yeah after social network you did a Lone
Ranger which was like yeah really big
letdown for a lot of people well
hopefully can I see this cuz I think
this will be a good way to maybe pull
him back into this yeah I mean anybody
called The Man From UNCLE which a lot of
you presently liked but I don't think
people were like I'm all about Ari
hammer now ya hear this seems like a
great role to do it's like Reservoir
Dogs yeah yeah yeah like with a little
bit more of that it is produced by
source AZ and it does have us where cz
kind of like dialog flare - and it seems
like they take time to also do some cool
shots and some cool
yeah but it's not like super dark out
like The Departed was yeah where it's
not serious yeah not at all which is
great yeah this looks like a fun violent
nasty time yes and with some awesome
performances I love watching actors get
together just have a blast
this looks like a really cool time yeah
I'm sorry I took so long to get around
to it well I appreciate that you waited
because I get to be here to wait yeah it
looks like you could be in a film like
this I'll show your facial hair kick in
no thank you like a German character ah
gah dah no who is Jack Rainer they
credited him and he looked very familiar
oh yeah he's that young guy who's in
sing Street I think that's what's called
sing sing yes oh he was in that short
film Stella which everyone saw he was
also in that short film car film which I
love he was in dollhouses transformers
age of extinction so I know I've seen
him in something alright ray Jackson do
the channel subscribe today get accepted
Kyle either man all the social media
links are in the description box yes he
sometimes likes to do live streams and
such I do and shout out to whoever
requested this video thank you so much
persistence wears down resistance my
friend no don't apply that with women
that could lead to illegal charges so
take care on that note